[Musique]
c'est la maison de rêve de sylvia de
kent en plein coeur des laurentides on a
acheté la maison pour vivre au bord de
l'eau pour pouvoir faire des activités
nautiques
pour pouvoir se ressourcer la vue
bucolique du lac a su charmer la
nouvelle résidente de val morin c'était
là la qualité de vie en nature eux
c'est pour ça qu'on s'est installé ici
elle et ses voisins se sont réveillés
mardi matin dans un bien mauvais rêve au
bord du lac dream
matin on se rend compte que les niveaux
du laki
l'étendue d'eau c'est pratiquement vidé
en une nuit alors que la municipalité a
procédé au retrait de poutrelles sur le
barrage servant à contrôler le niveau du
lac un assèchement qui a pris des
riverains par surprise pour moi c'est
inacceptable
je ne peux pas comprendre qu'on va
causer un tort à tout un écosystème
parce qu'on a des difficultés enlevé
deux poutrelles le barrage doit
absolument être ouverts avant la saison
froide ce qui entraîne le vidage du lac
dring nous répond la municipalité les
ingénieurs craint qu'un tel ouvrage ne
résiste pas à une crue soudaine en plein
hiver au printemps puisqu'il est
impossible pour eux d'ouvrir le barrage
lors de ses saisons vraiment un enjeu de
sécurité pour les employés donc c'est ce
passé des poutres de bois en fait qui se
gorgent d'eau et ça gèle et c'est plus
enviable au divin
le mariage est pourtant neuf il a été
reconstruit après des inondations
historiques en 2016 qui ont fait céder
l'ancien coût du projet plus de 400
mille dollars mais depuis le niveau de
l'eau n'est pas stable selon les
riverains inquiets pour la santé du lac
je sais pas si vous mourez à la langue
mais ça ça va ça avance ça avance
les résidents de quoi être préoccupé le
vidage annuel de l'acq n'est pas sans
conséquence selon cette experte c'est
vraiment appauvrir l'écosystème
aquatique et empêcher les espèces qui
seront notamment présents dans un lac il
s'installe et ce soit quelqu'un qu'on
voit souvent trop c'est raide et
alassane ça nous fait un pincement au
coeur
la municipalité assure de son côté que
ces actions sont sans conséquences ici
giran bergeron radio-canada balmoral